Improve Your react skills by learning to build
a dictionary app. In this course from roadside
coder, the dictionary uses material UI and
supports 12 languages. Hey, everyone, welcome
back to Free Code Camp. And today we are going to
build an awesome dictionary app using react js and
material UI. So this video has two sections. In
the first one, we are going to build and deploy
this app on netlify. And in the second section,
we will convert it into a pw a or progressive
web app, so that you can install this app as
a native Android or iOS app into your phone.
So let's explore this app first. So this
dictionary has support of over 12 languages.
Let's search a word real quick. Let's search
plain. Now you can see it provides the definition,
example and the synonym for that particular word.
And not only one definition, it provides all the
definition of that particular word. And what's
even better is this pronounciation audio, you can
play this plane, it tells you the pronunciation of
that particular word. So yeah, that's awesome. And
I guess just pronunciation is supported in English
only. So let's go to Hindi language. And I'm going
to search my name, which is bu ish. And here you
go, you have the meaning of this particular name.
So this is an amazing app. Now what's better in
this app is you see in this little corner over
here, Tara, light mode and dark mode, he has that
amazing feature of this app, you can implement it
by using material UI as well as swamp. That's
why I've chosen material UI because it's so
easy to implement this dark mode and light mode
feature in material UI. Also, if you're interested
in more tutorials on react js, be sure to check
out my channel, which is called roadside coder.
Recently, I've uploaded a full fledged myrn
stack project tutorial with Redux on my channel,
link will be in the description below. So
without any further ado, let's get started.
So what we're going to do is we're going to open
a new project real quick, let me select my folder.
I'm gonna go over here and
select this particular folder.
I mean, let me close these files real quick. Yeah,
so we need to go to our terminal and type and
PX create react app. And we're gonna name this,
we're gonna name this app word, hunt, oops,
I made a mistake. Let me correct this NPM to NP
x and press Enter. Now what it's going to do,
it's going to go to the NPM repository, it's
going to take all of the files needed to create
our create react app, I'm going to bring them over
into this word hunt folder. So Meanwhile, this is
initializing. Let me just show you the API that
we're going to use for this app. So the API that
we're going to use is called Google dictionary
API. This is an official Google dictionary API
created by this guy, me developer. Thank
you so much, the developer for this API.
So this API provides us these support of these
many languages. And how are we going to use
this API, we're gonna provide a language code to
this API and a particular word. So it's gonna go
and fetch data in this form. So we're going
to, we're going to see how we can deal with
this data later. So you can see we have a language
support, or here with over these many languages,
English and the Spanish, French excetera. Love
Languages over here. This is an amazing API.
So yeah, also, let's explore material
UI real quick. So what is material why
material UI is a react components for
faster and easier web development.
It's a react component library. Now what is
a react component library. So react component
library is something which provides you with a
prebuilt, no prebuilt component in this particular
library, which you can use in your own project.
Let me show you by clicking get started over here.
I'm going to close this project, which was already
open. So yeah, we can install this by using NPM,
install material, UI slash core. So
we're gonna install this as well. Let me
see if our app has installed. No, it's still
getting installed. Let's just wait for that.
So it also provides us material UI icons. So this,
let's just leave this for later. I'm going to show
you how you can use this library. Now. Let's go
to the components and let's go to button. Alright,
you can see we have different different types
of buttons over here. So you these are pre built
buttons in the material UI library, you can just
straight up import them by just typing one line.
When you type this line, this button will be
important. If you change the color to primary,
this button will be imported. So yeah, this is an
amazing library. And you might be thinking there
might be other libraries as well. Yes, there are.
There's one library called react bootstrap. I use
this library all the time. But I decided to use
this material UI library because it's really easy
to work on light and dark feature as well. And
you'll also get to explore something new in react.
So yeah, bootstrap is really, you know, mainstream
type of library, but material wise making it plays
in the market. So we are materializing a
really good library. So what are we going
to use from this material library, we're going
to use something called text field as a text,
limiter via text field over there. So
actually, we're going to use this component
right here. So what it's gonna do, it's
gonna provide us a pre built input component,
where we can search our particular word, we're
gonna use that, and we're gonna use this select
where to go, yeah, here, here it is, we're
gonna use this select component as well.
Alright, so let's check if our app
has initialized successfully or not.
Yes, it has initialized successfully,
let me just switch to this by typing cd,
word hunt. Or what you can do is go to File, Open
Folder, and just go to your particular folder,
in my case, this folder and select this
folder. And here it is, it has opened that
particular folder in a separate window. So
let's go to this. And we're going to first
of all installed material UI. So yeah, let's
go over here, where was that particular line?
Let's go to installation and copy this line over
here, copy and paste it over here. So it's gonna
take a little bit of time to install material
UI, because material wire is a huge library.
So it just takes a little bit of time.
So once it's installed, I'll be back
one, eternity later. All right, finally, our
material UI library has installed successfully.
So what we're going to do now with our react
app is that we're going to get rid of the
useless files that we don't need right now. So
let's delete these files, these four files over
here. We're not we don't need these files at
all. But first of all, let me just run this app
for the first time, and I'm going to show you
how this looks when it runs for the first time.
So here it is, this is our react app successfully
started. So what I'm going to do, I'm going
to just dock it right over here. And I'm going
to delete these files, as I mentioned earlier,
so let's just delete these four files. And let's
go to and you can see, this app is now going to
complain because it it was using those files
somewhere. So let's just check. So logo was
being used over here, we don't need it, we're just
gonna get rid of all of this information inside of
this file over here. We're gonna go to index j
s, we're gonna remove this. We're gonna remove
this. And that's pretty much it. Let's go to our
app. J s and run Hello, world. Hello, world. Yep.
There you go. Hello, world, but it boots in the
center. Because I think we haven't removed these
tiles yet. Let's remove all of these tiles in the
app j s, we're not going to touch the index CSS or
index j s right now. Because we don't need right
now or anywhere, any time because we don't need to
do anything with them. So yeah, the HelloWorld
has been successfully printed over here.
Alright, so what? What are we going to do
first? So let's just import our API in our app
real quick. Let's go to our API website. Was that
dictionary? API? Let me just check. Yep, there it
is. Revolutionary API, we're going to need this
particular link. But how are we going to fetch
this link, we're going to use a package called
axios. So we're going to need to install that
package. So I'm going to open another terminal
over here. And we're going to go NPM I axios.
And here we go. axios has been successfully
installed. So what are we going to do now
we're gonna create a function. Let's call this
function dictionary API. Just a second. Yeah,
we're gonna call this function dictionary API.
We're going to create an arrow function over
here. And also, since we are fetching the
API, we need to make this function async.
We need to make this an asynchronous functions.
And we're going to type try catch over here to
catch if any error ever occurs in our app. So
I'm going to just log this error right here.
And inside of the try, block, what we're going to
do, first of all, let me close this terminal over
here. So yeah, we're back in line In terminal,
so what are we going to do in this try block,
we're going to fetch that API. So const, let's
type data equals await. So we need this await
keyword inside of this async function, otherwise,
it's going to give us error. So axios dot get.
So let's copy the link from the website. This
is the link. Let's copy this link over here.
Alright, you see, you can see there's some
language code let's just provide is by default,
an English word, sorry, English keyword, whatever.
So and word for word, I'm just gonna give it let's
just give it plain. Alright, so also, we're
going to need to call this function somewhere.
So we are going to call this function, we're
going to use something called use effect.
Use effect. So what is use effect all about?
Let me clear it up. Use it use effect is,
when you keep these brackets empty over here, use
effect is called whenever your component is first
time rendered. But if you keep anything inside of
these brackets, or those are called dependencies,
then what is going to do it's going to be called
every time those variables are going to change.
You're going to know along the way, so I'm going
to call this dictionary API inside of this use
effect. Let's see what happens. useeffect is not
defined, obviously, because we haven't imported
you is a fact. Yes. I'm going to import.
Use effect. Whoops, what just happened?
Use effect from react. Yep. It's not gonna give
me any of that. No, yep. Data is a sign of value,
but never use. Obviously, we have called this
data variable, but we haven't used it. Let's just
log this. Let's see what we get in this API. I'm
going to log this over here and go to our browser
and go to our app. And you can see our app is
empty currently. Let's just print dictionary.
Yeah, that's all. Yep, dictionary, the word there.
So let's check the console real quick. What do we
get inside our console? So we get we're getting
this data we're getting called fake data headers,
etc, which is going to need this data array over
here. So inside of these, each of this array,
there is a different meaning for this word called
plain. So let's go to inside. Let's go inside of
one item. And inside of one item, we can see there
are two sections. First is meaning, and the other
one is phonetics. So for inside of phonetics,
we're getting this link. Yep, that's the
pronounciation for this particular word. So we're
going to use that later. First of all, we need to
use this meanings item inside of this array
item. So let's go to the meaning item, we
can see another array objects. So in each inside
of each of these objects, we have a definition.
We have example. And we have
synonyms for that particular word.
So this is how this API is going to work. So
let's use it. So first of all, what do we need,
we're going to go inside of this and take
this data for that for using that data and
storing it somewhere else, we're going to
create something called a state in react,
we're going to type use state, whoops, use est,
enter, you can see it has given us this code. And
we're going to name this meanings. And since
it's going to be an array, so we're going to
give this an empty array to begin with. This
part right here contains the initial state of
this particular state. And this is going to be
the function which we're going to use to change
the state. And this is going to be an actual
variable. Let me show you now it's going to
complain because we haven't imported the US state
yet. So let's just import use state from react.
Alright, so we're gonna import
all of this data inside of that
set meanings. So let's just
enter and set with one second,
set meanings. And inside of set meanings. We're
going to type data. Whoops, data dot data.
Yep. And let's just log this meanings. I'm
gonna go down here and log this meanings. Yeah.
Let's check our browser. Let's
refresh this page for once.
And you can see we are getting
the only the data part of that API
table so We need these meanings. Anyway. So
let's just see what are we going to do next.
So first of all, what we need to do is we
need to create another state. For our word
that's gonna be empty by default. Let's start
by creating the header section of our app.
First of all, we're going to go to material
UI, again, what I'm going to introduce you to
something called container in material UI. So
this container helps a lot in making your app
responsive. Whenever the screen size of your app
changes, it's going to adapt to that particular
size. Let me show you all real quick. So inside
of this app Dev, what I'm going to go and write is
contain this container tag, and you can see VS
code has automatically imported this container.
If you go and press CTR space, it's going to
show you the suggestions and you can click on the
particular session to automatically import that.
And I'm going to give this container a max width
of medium MD, you can go through all of
this max with medium small inside of this
documentation of material UI, you can see
they've given you a small size and accept,
accept accept Trump. Now we'll see what
happens to our app, let's just type dictionary.
Let's see what happens. Alright, let me close
this terminal. And you can see your dictionary
has been aligned to the center of the very center.
And you can see when I'm resizing this window,
you can see it's adapting to that particular,
the container is helping our screen to adapt to
the screen size. So this is how container helps
us out. Let me give this a few styles as well.
I'm going to provide it some inline
styles with the height of 100, viewport.
And the background color. Background Color where
it is yeah, it's over here. I'm gonna give it
hash 282 c three, four. Let's see how that looks.
Yep, that's looking good. But our dictionary has
been hidden. So I'm going to give it a color
as well. So color, it's going to be white.
Yep, that's pretty much it. Looks pretty.
Alright, so we're gonna give a few styles
to our container as well. So as you all might be
aware of Flexbox what Flexbox is all about in CSS,
we're gonna we're gonna give it a style of
display, flex so that all of the items are
aligned from top to bottom, we're going
to give it flex direction, column.
Here we go. And we're going to
give it a height of 100 we edge
and the justify content. Okay, I'm not going
to give it right now I'm going to show you
all later why that's useful to us. So first of
all, let me just work on this header part over
here where our heading, and our search
and select box is going to lie. Alright,
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to go to
SRC, and create a new folder called components.
And inside of this component, I'm going to
create a new file or a new folder called header.
Now in zardoz header folder, when you create a
new file called header dot j s, and another file
for CSS as well header dot CSS. So let's go to
header dot j s, I'm going to show you a shortcut,
r A, F, C E, if you go and type this and press
enter, it's going to give you a boilerplate
code for a basic react function. So let's create
this header component real quick. First of all,
I'm just going to go and type header. Or I'm
going to use let's say a title over here.
I'm going to give it a span tag. Give it a class
name of title. I'm going to All right. Word,
hunt. Yep, that looks good. Let's give this a
class name as well. Off header. Yep, that looks
good. Let's just import this inside of our app,
your app.js. Let me get rid of this dictionary
over here. And I'm going to type header. Now you
can see it's giving us auto import suggestions.
So we're gonna click on that. And you can see
header has been automatically imported over here.
So we're gonna make a self closing tag.
And let's see if it has rendered or not.
Here we go. word count has been rendered.
Sandra style this word 100. Real quick.
I'm going to go to header header dot CSS.
But first of all, we need to import this
CSS file inside of this header. How are we
going to do that? We need to type import
dot slash dot means current
directory slash header dot CSS.
Whoops. Yeah, that looks good. Now we're gonna
have to provide this title, some styling,
that just provide this title, a little bit
of styling. Let's just say font size of
seven viewport width. viewport width is the
width of the screen that you're currently on
on your phone or your on your computer. It's
that particular width. I'm going to type text
trans form to uppercase. So that it's capital, and
I'm going to give it font family. First of all,
let's just not give it font family. Now let's
just check this. Okay, it's looking good,
but it's looking kind of ugly. So we want this
to be a little bit of pretty. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go to Google, Google. Sorry,
Google, I'm gonna type Monserrat font, if I'm not
wrong with the spelling, yeah, Montserrat.
So we need this Montserrat font over here.
I'm going to go over here. 10 100. Select this
style, and go to import. And I'm going to take
this font over here. I'm going to copy this.
And I'm going to go back to our text editor and
I'm going to go to index dot CSS. Just add right
at the top. I'm going to paste this font style.
Now let's see what happens. If we
type font family. We're gonna need
to correct spelling m o n d, e s e r
r a t. Yep. Correct. And sans serif?
Let's go and check. Look, it doesn't work.
Why though? Hopefully, I've haven't put the
wrong spelling over here. Maybe I did? Yes, I did.
Okay, now let's see. Yeah, it looks really good.
So one piece of advice for you all, if you're
gonna make the world a little bit bigger,
the heading a little bit bigger, just reduce
its font weight. So it's gonna look pretty.
These are some of the design, you know,
tips for a while. So yeah, it looks good.
So what do we need, other than this heading
inside of our header, we're going to need the
text component, as you all know. So I'm
going to create another div over here.
Alright, I'm going to give class name of this
div as inputs. Yep. Also, I think we need to
style our header as well a little bit. I'm
going to bring in the styles for our header.
So what I'm going to do over here, what am
I doing over here, so I'm providing is a
display of flex align items to the center and
justify content of space evenly. So what is
going to do let me show you all slid have swapped
created this Dev, let me just say anything Hello.
If you go back over here, you can see it's
aligning from top to bottom. This is happening
because of this flex direction column, we have
set the display to flex flex direction column,
and we're setting display justify
content space evenly. So it's going to
have even space between them. And is going to
have the height of 35 viewport height. If I
increase this to let's say, 50 viewport height,
see you can see the height has been increased.
So we want is 35 viewport height you can see
there's a space between these components.
So and it is going to be 100%. So these are all
the styles. I'm not going to go too in depth in
the CSS because it's a react project, not the
CSS project. So yeah, bear with me. Alright,
so inside of inputs, what do we need now? We're
going to need a text field. So let's go to our
browser real quick, too much. Do you really why?
Let's go to the text field text field. Whoops,
here we go. We're gonna need this standard
text field. So I'm going to copy this up
and copy this right here and go to our text
editor. I'm going to paste this over here.
And you can see it's going to give us error
because the text field we have an important text
field yet, so we're gonna I'm gonna go over here,
CTR l space, it's gonna show me suggestion, I'm
gonna click over here, and you can see text field
has been imported. So yeah, VS code helps a lot
while coding. Okay, it's dark, right now you can
see because the background is also dark, and the
component is also dark. So it's not working
out. So what do we need to do over here?
We're going to import a dark theme over
here. Where do we find this dark theme? And
we're going to go to material UI, we're
going to search dark mode. Here we go.
And I'm just gonna copy this up. This one or
another one? Let me check. No, not this one.
We're gonna copy. Yeah, I think I'm gonna copy
that one. Yeah, we're gonna make a little bit
of changes to this one. So here's the dark theme,
it's gonna complain, because we haven't imported
create em UI theme. Let's click import that one as
well. So type is dark. So I'm gonna just what I'm
going to do, I'm going to copy the name, and go
inside of this, and import something called theme
provider. So theme provider allows us to, you
know, apply themes to the material UI components.
We're going to go over here, theme. So I've
auto imported this by typing CTL space,
you can see it has been auto imported. I'm gonna
go over here, type theme equals dark theme. Now
let's check our component real quick. Has it
improved? Yes, it has. But still, you can see
when I click over here, it goes a little bit of
dark blue. So we don't want that. So what are we
going to do over here? inside of the palette,
we're going to provide it a primary color.
Primary of main, it's going to be how hash, F F F.
Also, comma is needed over here. I think this
should work. Here we go. When we click on it,
it's gonna go active with a white color. So yeah,
we've imported our dark theme over here. What do
we need other than this? We're going to need a
select component. Let's find our select component.
Let me go back to the text field. Yep. Let
me scroll down to here. This is what we need.
All right. Okay. Whoops. Yeah, I'm going to click
over here. You can see it's provided us a ton of
code over here. So what do we need? We need the
first one, right? Yeah, we need the first one.
I'm going to go and copy this one, this text field
over here, from here to here. Let's copy it up.
Paste it over here. It's gonna complain because
it's missing a lot of things. First of all,
this text field is all yeah, that's
important. We don't need this menu item,
I'm going to go CTL space and press enter.
So my new item is important. But you can see
these currency and handle change. These are all
their data, they are not presenting the file,
you can see currency handle change currencies. So
what are we going to need this select for? First
of all, we're going to need this select for our
countries. Let me just remove this. Remove this.
This map function as well. Yeah,
we're going to use desc later.
Yeah, inside of the menu item, I'm going to type,
let's say English. I'm going to
remove these key and values as well.
Let's see if it works or not. It does. Yep,
you can see, but it has only one component.
So what do we need to do, we
need to import all of these
languages. So what I have done for
you have already created a file.
Over here, let me just go to text editor and
create another folder with the name of data.
And I'm gonna go and create
a new file called category.
Category dot j s. Yep, category dot j
s inside of this category. I'm going to
Go and provide this particular data. So if you
want this particular data, what do you need to do,
I'm going to provide link in the description to
my GitHub repo, you're gonna go to my GitHub repo,
you're gonna go to this particular GitHub
repo, you're gonna go to SRC, to the data
to the category.js, you're going to copy this
file, I'm going to copy this inside of your code,
so we're just going to do is it providing the
value, and the label is just in the documentation
of that API, you can create it yourself, or you
can copy it from my GitHub. So we have created
this category.js. Let's save it. And inside
of our header.js, I'm going to import this up.
Right here import category from,
I'm going to go one step backwards.
Another step backwards, and inside of the data,
you're going to need category, here we go.
So we need this category variable right here.
So we're gonna, we're gonna map through this,
inside of this menu item. So what I'm
going to do now, this, and category
roadmap, we're gonna go and look through this,
I'm gonna provide this menu item inside of it.
And let's give this name, variable name.
give it the name of option. And inside
of this, we're gonna go and type option,
dot value, because we want the value to be inside
of our select box. Let's see if it works or not.
Yes, it does. But we need to provide it a
key and value as well. So let's go over here.
inside of this key, I'm going to type
option dot value. Sorry, option dot label.
and the value will be option dot label. Let's
save this real quick. And let's check it out.
Still the same? What do we need to do now? We
need to provide a value to over here as well.
So we had earlier created a state for
this, I guess we haven't created a state.
So let's just create a state called category.
So I'm sorry, whoops, what am I doing?
US state? category? Yep, that looks fine. And I'm
going to provide a default value of English. Yep.
We need to bring both of these things to that
header component. How are we going to do that?
We're going to go over here
to the header component. To
this, we're going to send this as a prop,
the category and the set category as well.
Yeah. So we're going to go inside of our header,
and we're going to receive these both variables
over here. But doing destructuring by
typing curly braces, enter, and Diggory.
Yeah, both of these are over here. Let me just
rename this to categories. Get a go race. So
we don't get confused between this and this. So
categories, yep, that's fine. All right. So what
the value is going to be value is going to be
category. And on change where it's going to do
it on chain, it's going to set that particular
category on that thing. So on change,
we're gonna have an event set category, e dot
target, dot value. Let's save this and check
this out. Hopefully should display language first.
Yes, it's displaying English over here. Alright,
let's make this thing work. Its display displaying
standard currently, we're gonna also have to
name that one as well. So we're just not going
to need this ID over here. In place of label
we're gonna type search word. And we're
going to give it a class name of search.
Oops, doing this in the wrong place.
It's supposed to be over here.
Both of these things are supposed to be over here.
There was the select one. So instead of the
select one, what we're going to do, we're
going to label it language. And we don't need
this helper text right here. Let's remove that.
Okay. Alright, so inside of this one, we need to
bring our word state that we created. Let me show
you what. Where is it? Yep, word and set word. I'm
going to take both of these and send it to header.
So word equals word. And set word equals set word.
There's not going to be any commas over here.
So yeah, we have sent this, let's just
receive them over here. Word and set word.
Yes, I'm going to give this a value of word.
And on change, what's going to happen on
change? It's gonna change that set word. So he
set word, e dot target, dot value, let's see this
thing in action. What I'm going to do over here,
is I'm going to check if, is there anything in
Word? I'm going to type like this in curly braces?
Is there anything in Word question mark? If
there's anything in Word, we're gonna render word.
Otherwise, what we're gonna do,
we're gonna render, word hunt.
It's going to update it in real time. There, check
it out. Let's type over here. Look, you can see,
it's working absolutely fine. Whenever we
changing it. It's calling this on change function,
to change this state, and providing this
particular value to this particular box.
And changing this, if there's nothing inside of
it, it's not going to change if there's anything.
Yep, it's working fine. All right, I see a
problem. What here? Why is this compressed?
So little, because it doesn't have a way over
here. And neither does this thing over? Here
have a bit. So let's see what I'm going to do. I'm
going to give it a class name of search, I'm gonna
give this a class name. Let's give it a class
name of select. Yeah, that's fine. Now I'm
going to go to header dot CSS, first of all, I
need to provide inputs A little bit of styling.
Also, we need to make sure of one thing over here,
I'm going to make these two responsive as well.
Because when you go over here, when you make this
smaller, you can see what hunt becomes little
too much tiny. So we want this to look a little
bit of better than that. So we're gonna make it
responsive. So we're gonna make it responsive
by using media queries. So add media, whoops,
media, we are type max width. If the max width is
lesser than 900 pixels, what's going to happen?
It's going to do is dot header is going to
make header justify content space evenly. And
height is gonna be 25 years, we're
going to decrease a height a little bit.
Second thing, what we're going to do is in the
title, we're gonna increase the font size of
this word hunt. So font size of, let's say,
11, VH. Whoops, what does happen over here?
I think I need to provide it a little bit
more of a height. Let me check. No, it's fine.
Let's see. If I go over here and provide styling
to inputs, I'm going to style the inputs first.
I'm going to provide it a width of 100%.
And I'm going to provide a display of
flex and justify content. I'm going to
provide it a space between these space around
so you can see it has the space between of
these. Let's check this I think I need to make it
with the width of 100% if I'm not wrong, but
I have provided the weight of 100% then what's
wrong over here? This is correct and just fine. In
the center, hello, sorry, spaced evenly. I don't
think I need to provide it over here once again,
so I'm gonna remove that. Everything looks fine.
Let's figure it out later. For now what
I'm going to do, okay, that's the problem
I have given it v. H, I need to give it v
w. Yeah, that was the problem, because it
was in respect to the height of the screen. Okay,
that was a problem. So yeah, it looks good. Now.
You can see, it doesn't get shrinked
too much. When responsive. So yeah,
we're talking about this, let's give it a
little bit of weight over here. First of all,
I'm going to style this input box over here.
So search, search is gonna have a width of 43%.
And same is gonna be for select as well.
So I'm going to do is comma, dot select.
Both of these classes are going to have 43%. Yep,
that looks pretty, you can see looks really good.
If you provide anything, it's going to change the
state. So here we go, we are done with our header.
Let's go to our app JS again, let's see if we have
anything left in our header over here. I don't
think we have anything left in the header.
All right, one more thing I think I'm going to do
is whenever we type, we're going to search a text,
let's say if I search plain, and if I
change the category, so what it should do,
it should clear this out, and the meanings
part as well. The meaning state as well.
So what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna create another
function over here, const, handle change.
So we're gonna call this function right here, this
text field, I'm gonna call this function right
here. And inside of this, since it's sending us
this e dot target dot value, we're gonna receive
it over here, what this value has it value has the
language. We're gonna provide this language to set
category. language should work still the
same, and the set world should be empty. Now.
Let's try this out. Can I change our
category? Yep, it's empty. If I type anything,
change it. Yeah, it's empty. It's working. Great.
Alright, one more thing that we need to do, that
we have left out is how do we change our API? When
we change this box, or this particular select
box? So we're going to use backticks over here,
remove these normal string tags. And
we're going to use the backtick and go to
language part. We're going to type dollar sign and
these curly braces, I'm going to type category.
Antara instead of this word. We're
gonna do the same thing and type word.
Great. Let's let's check if
our API is responding to that.
Whoops, what just happened? Yeah. Let's go
to our console. Yeah, it's, it's showing an
error because there's nothing inside of it.
Let's just type Hello. And again, see? Yep.
What was it still showing what okay, because
I think I have no words. I haven't worried it.
Fine, it looks fine. Let's just reload
this page once again. And type Hello. Okay.
Okay, React hooks has a missing dependency, of
course, because we need to call this API every
time we change our world or category. So we're
gonna provide it word and category. So that is
what's gonna happen. That is what was wrong in
the previous one. Every time we change this word,
let's say hello. That's gonna call the API again.
You can see it's calling the API. And you can see
it's providing us with the meaning and everything
that we need to work with. Yep, that's great.
That is what we need. So let's start working
on this. We're gonna remove have this console
over, let it be over here. We're going to work
on this below pike. So what I'm going to do,
I'm going to create another component for that.
I'm going to go Here, instead of our components,
we'll create a new folder called, let's say
definitions. I'm going to make it a capital.
It's very important. Not the folder, but the
file that you create. It should be in the capital
guard GS, and another file for CSS. I think
I have created it inside of the header. So
I'm going to take it out of the header.
Yeah, now it's fine. So our definition.js,
let's go and type A f c and get the
boilerplate code. Let's just type Hello.
And I'm going to import it. First of all,
let me just create a CSS file for it as well.
Definitions dot CSS and import that CSS file
inside of here. Import dot slash definitions.
dot CSS? Whoops. Yeah. Let's just
import the definitions in our app j s.
Below this header. I'm going to type definitions.
Yes. exhibits out auto imported. Yes, it has.
Let's go to our app and check. Yes,
hello, is printed over here successfully.
Great. So what do we need to create inside of
the definitions, we need to create a box as I
showed you earlier, inside of that, we're going
to render all of our meanings for this particular,
you know, Word, and the category. So let's see
what are all the things that we need to send
to the definition? So I think we're going to need
to send this word and the category and no, ha,
yeah, we're gonna need to send this word and
the meanings because the categories not needed
over there. Because category is changing the
API. That's all it's doing. So we're gonna
send the word, let's first of all, send the
word. And we're gonna send the meanings state.
All right. And we're gonna set the category as
well. Let's see if we need that or not. category.
Let's just close the useless folders.
Yeah, let's go back to the definition
and receive all of that word here. Word,
category. And meanings. Alright, let's save this.
Also, I'm gonna render this definitions only
when there's something inside of that meanings.
You know, if there's nothing inside of the state,
then we don't need to see anything over here.
So what I'm going to do is when a provided
in curly braces, when they say meanings,
and this, so there's something inside of the
meanings only, then the definitions will be
rendered. Let's go inside of the definitions.
And let's see. So first of all, we're going to
need an audio component as well, but I'm going
to leave that audio component for the later.
So let's just start by typing. If there's anything
inside of the word, so So if, if there's nothing
inside of the word, first of all, what it's
going to render, it's gonna render a span tag.
A span tag, the class name of, let's say, sub,
title, whoops. title. And it's gonna say start
by typing a word in search. Yeah. What
if there's something inside of the word
where it's gonna render? To render this
something else? Let's say something.
There's something over here. Oops. I'm
just gonna do this. Yeah. Let's see.
Yeah, start by typing a word
in. So let me just style it
a little bit. I'm gonna provide this
div a class name of, let's say meanings,
or meanings. We have imported at CSS all as well.
There's a style both of these
first, so that we're done with that.
I'm going to go and type meanings. What are we
going to do first of all, we need a border as I
displayed earlier, but first of all we're going to
do is going to type Display flex, brilliant, we're
going to need to make it flex box. And we need
everything to be aligned from top to bottom.
From top to bottom. We're going
to do flex direction has column.
And yeah, and we're going to do when there's
a lot of items being displayed over here,
we're gonna have to do overflow. Why
as a scroll? Or flow? Why as scroll?
You know what I'm thinking, let's just apply this
style later. So that, wait, something's wrong. No.
30, something to see, first of all, I'm going
to import something instead of instead of this
something written over here. So yeah, well, first
of all, let me demonstrate if it's working or not.
You have anything you can see there's something
printed, if it's nothing, it's going to say start
by having a word in search. Let's style this
subtitle. I'm gonna go and style this subtitle
only. For now. So title, I'm going to give it a
font size of similar font size that we provided
earlier, five, viewport width, and the
font family is going to be the same.
Monserrat, let me just copy it so that I
don't make any spelling mistake this time.
Yep. Yeah, that looks good. To me, font
size five VH. And what I'm thinking?
No, yeah, that's fine. Anyway, so
yeah, well, what we're going to do,
we are going to render this meanings instead
of this thing. So let's go over here.
I'm going to type meanings. I'm going to map
through this. And map. I'm going to give it
a word mean. And just do that. Let's just log
it. Let's see what we get inside of it. I mean,
there's something wrong. Yeah, semicolon. Let's
see, what do we get? If I type anything plain?
Well, you can see we get a lot of things over
here, we get an array of word and the phonetics
and Okay, that's not the final word that this
is the final word. We're getting meanings and
the phonetics so we need to hurry through this
meanings. For going, I'm going to remove this now.
Alright, so what I'm going to do is get
out of here, your mean, dot meanings. dot
map. I'm going to name this variable as item.
Let's see what's inside of it. Let's log it. Item.
Now, let's log base real quick. And first
of all, I need to remove this log from here,
so it doesn't create some confusion. Let me
just close this terminal. Yeah, make some space.
Let's see what we get. Let me refresh
this over here. I'm gonna type plane.
There we go, we can see a lot of things
over here we can see our definitions.
So now we need to render, you know, map through
this definitions. So we get each each of the
definitions and the other thing has to be synonyms
and examples. Okay, it doesn't have over here.
It's gonna be somewhere right
here. definitions. What's going on?
Let me just check this.
It has to be inside of this somewhere.
It's gonna be somewhere inside of this.
parts of speech parts of speech definitions.
You can see example. And this one has one extra
thing it's going to be synonym. We're going to
make this example in synonymous optionally,
because you can see somewhere it's appearing
somewhere, it's not appearing. So we're gonna
make that optional. So let's go back to our code.
Let's just remove this inside of it. I think I
removed something else. Do something wrong. No.
I'm supposed to remove this. Yes, so inside of
this. So we have our item. So with our item,
let me shift it backward here. With our item what
what are we going to do we need definitions. We're
going to map to definition. I know this is a lot
of mapping over here. This isn't mapping hell. So
I'm going to do is definitely item dot definitions
dot map, and let's give it the variable name at D,
F. Alright, now we need to create a div.
Whoops, the IB. Yeah, there's our div,
I'm going to give it a class name of
single meaning, or single mean, whatever you
want to call it, I'm gonna give it a style.
Little bit of styling. I'm giving I'm gonna
give it a background color. The single
component is going to have a background color
of white, let's say. And what else do we need,
I'm gonna give it since it's wide,
I'm gonna make the content as black,
color, black. Let's see if I type
anything inside of this. Let's print
our definition first. So I'm going to print
the definition in bold. So def dot definition.
Let's check. Alright, here we go. These are the
different definitions that we're getting from the
API for the word plane. If I type ball, here we
go. We're getting different, different meanings
for the ball. So we did we just don't need just
the definitions, we're going to need the examples
as well. So I'm going to create a line between
both of these. I'm going to give it a style of
background color. Black and the width,
not the width of 100%. Let's say.
I hope it's gonna create a little bit
of separation. Yep, it does. mean see
this overflow is also over here. I'm going to
hide it in a while. So we have got this HR No.
All right. Now these optional parts
def dot example. If there's an example,
then where are we going to print this, we're going
to create a span tag. Instead of the span tag,
first of all, we need to type example. So we're
going to make the example as bold example.
All right, and we're gonna print d
f dot example. Let's check that out.
Okay, this is not appropriate. It was having
some shady meanings. Yeah. So yeah, you can
see example definition. Definition example.
Yeah. There you go. So what else do we need?
We need the synonyms. Right below the
example. I'm going to type def dot synonym.
If the synonym exist, synonym s, also is going
to be there. So if doesn't only exist, what are
we going to do, we're going to do the same thing
that we did over here, we're going to copy this.
I'm going to paste it over here. I'm just going
to change synonyms. And d f, dot synonyms.
synonyms, since they are many synonyms, I'm
going to do I can do a map through the synonyms.
s. And I'm going to do with the
backtick. I'm going to do is this.
I'm going to print s and comma. Let's see how
that looks. You can see synonyms example, but
looks kind of ugly, you know it's
in the same line. So we need to do,
what do we need to do is we're going to have this
in all this in different lines. So first of all,
let's just style the outer container first. I'm
going to style this meanings container first,
right? When I go to definitions dot CSS, and
let's continue from here. I'm going to type this
ugly scroll bar I need to make it a little
bit smaller. So I'm going to type scroll
with I think, yep, scroll bar width, I'm going
to give it 10. Now you can see a scroll bar is
looking much better. You can see the side scroll
bar is thinner. I'm gonna give it a height of
55 viewport height and the border and get a border
of 10 pixels 10 pixels of solid I have a color
over here, we're going to copy this, you can just
copy this color where you can just experiment with
these colors by clicking over here and just select
a color. I've chosen this color, it was looking
good. And I'm going to give it a border radius
of 10 pixels. Let's see how far it looks. Okay,
it's not very good, I think I need to give it some
padding. I'm going to give it a padding. In top
and bottom, I'm going to give it 10 pixels and
left and right, I'm going to give it 20 pixels.
And the overflow x will be hidden, we don't
want the bottom bar overflow x will be hidden.
Yes, we just need this bar. Also, we need to
create some separations between these two. Now I'm
gonna provide that style. But let me just check
if it's responsive right now. So if you can see,
we make it smaller. It has a little bit of
gap between this. I mean, below this. We're
gonna make it a little bit higher height when
it's smaller. So I'm gonna do a media query.
max width of 900 pixels. Let's do his meanings.
Yep, meanings, and I'm gonna give it a height
of 60, viewport height. Yep,
looks much better. And overflow.
See, why am I leaving a little bit of space over
here, because we're going to have a component
at the top, which is going to be responsible
for switching our themes. So I'm just leaving
the space for that. overflow, x is going to be
hidden and overflow is gonna be scroll. Yeah.
Better. So in this single meaning component,
let me just get back to this. In this single
meaning component, we need to style this div
as well, you know, each of this devs need to
style this as well. I'm gonna go over here. I'm
gonna type display flex. The moment I type this,
you can see it's just all horizontal line. It
looks really ugly. So I'm going to type flex
direction as column. Yep, that's a lot
better. I'm going to give it border radius
of let's say 10 pixels. Let's try it looks
good. Yeah, it's looking better. We'll just
create a spacing between them by padding of 10
pixels of top and bottom and left and right,
it's gonna be 20 pixels. Yep. Okay, four
spaces between now I need the margin.
For I just need the top and bottom spacing
and left and right is going to be zero.
Yeah, that's much better. You can see. So
we're halfway through off dictionary app.
Let's see if our Hindi works or not. I'm going to
type my name. Yep. It's looks. It's working man.
Great. Tap yourself in the back.
You've done a good job. Anyway,
putting the cringe aside. So what are we
going to do next? We're going to create a
theme switcher component? Do we need this
category? Now? I don't think we need it.
Let me just check. I think we're gonna
need this in our audio component. Yes,
I'm going to what I'm going to do is
while creating the audio component, if the
category is English, only, then we're gonna print
the audio component because audio component is
not available in the other languages. So
just create that real quick. So meanings.
It's only available in the first item of this
meanings array. So I'm going to type if meanings,
first item is available. And if there's
something inside of the word, if this is true,
and third thing that needs to be true,
is if there's something inside of Kanu
not something inside of I mean, if it's English,
if the category is English, if these three
conditions are true, then only it's going to
go and render our app. Sorry, audio component.
I'm going to go inside of here. And now I'm
going to render the audio component. Alright,
if the audio component not supported, I'm going to
type your browser doesn't support audio element.
That's better. I'll just have to give some message
or some shit like that. Sorry. Yeah. So inside
of this tile, we're gonna name background
color. We're gonna use a background color of
hash F F F, which is white, and the
border radius of 10. Let's see if it's
raining or not. Of course, it's not
raining because we haven't typed anything.
Still doesn't render. Okay, we haven't provided
it. Obviously, we haven't worded it the
SRC that's provided the src. So SRC will be inside
of our meanings. The first element of our meaning.
That's why I included the first element inside
the phonetics, as I showed you earlier, phonetics,
and sorry, phonetics, instead of
the first element of the phonetics.
So okay, sometimes what happens is the
phonetics is also missing. So I'm going
to test if the phonetics is present or
not. So phonetics is there, it's present,
then we're gonna type the same thing again. And
inside of this, there's something called audio.
And also, I'm going to provide it control. So we
have the controls to pause and play the audio etc.
Now, here we go clean, there you have it,
you have the audio component you there are
your controls to increase the audio or decrease
the audio, etc. So here's the audio component.
So what's the last thing that we need to do,
we need to create a theme switcher component,
we need to create a theme switcher component
over here. Alright, let's go back to our app j s.
And what I'm going to do, first of all,
I'm going to go back to this material,
you why I'm going to import something called
switch, we need because obviously when we're
gonna need a switch to switch the theme. So these
are the normal switches with secondary, primary,
uncontrolled etc, we are going to need a switch
which from which we're going to change its color.
So here's the custom color component, I'm gonna
copy this up, I'm gonna go over here and copy this
particular component, this is the component, you
can go through our documentation, you will also
understand what's going on over here. So I'm
going to copy this up. Let's go and see drlc
have copied it up. So inside of our app, j s,
I'm going to paste it right over here. And it's
going to complain, because some things are not
imported, like with styles. Let's import that
with styles. There's something else yeah, the
purple color, but we don't need a purple color.
We're gonna replace it with gray color. So enter,
you can see in gray color has also been important.
Switch is not defined. Yep, switch, we also
need to import the switch, important the switch,
and hopefully it's going to work,
or it's not going to show over here.
Until we render it down in our app. Let
me just create level of spacing over here.
Let's face over there, so I'm
just gonna render it right or no,
right over here inside of
our Comm. container. Yeah,
just above the header. What I'm going to
do is I'm going to give it another deal.
Because we're going to make this div as absolute.
So that is, the position of this div is always the
top right corner. Make this absolute and the
style is gonna be position as absolute. And
the top will be zero. Let me just write
something inside of this, let's say theme.
You'll see your team appears over here.
We're gonna make it right. With let's say 15.
Yeah, that's a sweet spot. And we're going
to provide a little bit of padding on the top
of 10. Great. Alright, now we
need to use this purple switch
still has the name of purple switch. Let me
just change the name of let's say theme change.
I hope it's not a prebuilt component,
material UI. I'll just call it dark mode.
Yeah, I'm going to call it dark mode. That's
better. To insert instead of this theme,
I'm gonna render the dark mode over here.
Here we go. Hopefully it's gonna render now.
Yup, there we go. Yes or So before this
dark mode, I need to provide a span tag,
which is going to say, some particular mode, let's
say for now it let's say it's saying light mode,
to switch the light mode, you can just press that,
and it's going to switch to that particular mode.
Also, inside of this dark mode, when we
need to provide a few of the components,
let's provide checked. c, h, e, k, Ed, yeah,
checked, equals, we're gonna provide a particular
state inside of it. So we need to create a state
four checked, just like a normal switch in HTML,
it's just going to work just like that, we're
going to provide a value and on change as well.
So let's quickly create state for our dark mode
in light mode, I'm going to go create a US state,
I'm going to call it light mode, I should
have called that component light mode as
well. But anyway, so light mode
by default is going to be false.
All right, because you can see, we're going to
load this app in dark mode, because our eyes are
useful, we don't want to get blind by light mode.
So your light mode over here and on change, it's
just gonna flip the switch. So what I'm going to
do is set light mode, and the opposite of whatever
the current value is. So opposite of light mode.
Yes. There we go. I think we need to provide the
styling to this thing. The flex is styling to
this thing. So I'm going to go inside of our
inside over here, I think I'm gonna have
to provide this a little bit of styling.
Or maybe our container, flex direction, column
height, 100, VH. Yes, we haven't provided the
justify content evenly. justify content,
space evenly. Space evenly. Now, you'll see
much prettier. Now. If you have any confusion
in the code, you just you can just go to my
GitHub repo, the link is provided in the
description to see all of the code changes,
if you have any confusion. I said that twice. Yes.
Yeah. So where was I was on here. Yeah, dark mode.
So what I'm going to do, if
person switches to light mode,
this led this text should also change.
First of all, let's take care of that.
I'm gonna provide a JavaScript tag over here. And
let's say light mode, if light mode is turned on,
then it's gonna render dark. Otherwise, it's gonna
render light. Let's see if that works or not.
By default, it's dark mode. So I'm going to turn
it on See, it's going to show dark mode, if I
turn it off light. Alright, so finally, here's the
moment of truth. How do we implement this feature?
So what do we need to do is wherever we have said
these colors, we just need to put a condition over
there. So let's start from best place from our
app component, I'm going to make it fullscreen.
And I'm going to check next check.
is like more turned on? If yes,
then I'm going to provide it a color of
white, triple F. Otherwise, that color.
And the color is also going to be affected by
this is the light mode turned on, we're gonna
ask this question again. If it sound, then I'm
gonna provide it black. Whoops, I can't type.
There we go. It's compiling. Let's just
test this out. Whoa, works like magic.
But we have still some things that we need to
take care of. Also, we just don't want this just
smacking the light mode in our face, just
we want to provide a type of transition
thread, it's soft, it looks good. We're
gonna provide all point five seconds,
you can just configure this according to your own.
And lenio now it's gonna be a little bit of soft
There you go. looks much better. So I'm going
to style this as well. Or where is that thing?
First of all, let me see if there's
anything needs to be changed or what here
and respect to dark mode or light mode? No,
I think we're gonna just send the light mode
over here in our header as well. So
that we can work With this thing,
right, and I'm going to set this over here as
well, man. Whoops, not the light theme. Light
mode. Whoa. Apparently I cannot
type light mode equals light mode.
I'm going to provide it to that theme. And
just go oops. I'm gonna go to our theme now.
I mean head now, I can't talk I
can't, right? I'm so stupid. Yeah.
Come don't use snort a very big tutorial. Light
mode See? light was gonna paste it. Light mode.
So over here, I'm going to check is the light
mode turned on? Question mark. If it's turned on,
I'm going to provide it a black color. Hash 000.
Otherwise, white. I'm going to check this again,
as it turned on. If it is I'm going to give it a
light theme. Otherwise, whoops. Otherwise dark.
Yo, let's check this out. Again. Pretty enough.
But let's type over here something. See?
Well, that doesn't look good. We need to
create it a little bit in that just need to
give something black theme or something. Let's
see if there's something remaining over here?
I don't think so. So we're going to provide the
same thing to our definitions component as well.
All right. Yep. Like mode. I'm gonna go to
which I already have came over here. So what I'm
going to do over here, let's see. Yep, right
here, we're gonna check if the light mode is
turned on or not. Question mark is the light
mode turned on. So we're going to provide it a
color of which was our background, three b 5360.
Otherwise, white. We're going to test this out
again over here, is there a light mode, then we're
going to provide it a white color, otherwise,
a black color? Let's check it out. Here
we go. Damn, that looks really pretty.
Really good. All right. And I think with this,
we have successfully created our app. Alright,
let's just quickly go to netlify.
And I'm going to host this website.
So how do we host these websites on netlify. So
I've already hosted his website on the netlify.
Already, this, this word hunt, I'm going to
click new site from get and then click on this
GitHub button over here, then I'm going to log in.
So you can see I've already authorized the GitHub,
so it's going to show my repositories, then
I'm going to select this react dictionary
repository where my code lies. So after pushing
it to the GitHub, you just need to click on this
deploy side button, and the site will be deployed.
And that's all that's all you need to do. And
let's say if you want to change the domain of
your website, where are you going to do, you're
going to go to your web app and click on domain
settings. Click on options added site name, and
you can provide a custom site name right here. So
what I'm going to do in the in our next video, I'm
going to make this application a pw a progressive
web app. So what is a pw a or progressive web app?
So pwd allows you to install a particular
web app into your phone natively. What I
mean by that is when you go to that web app into
your phone's browser or your desktops browser,
it's going to prompt you with an installation
icon. So when you press that installation prompt,
it's gonna start installing that app natively
into your phone. So you can use that app just
like a native app into your phone or desktop. So
this is an amazing feature of a progressive web
app. So let's get started. So as you can see,
we are running our dictionary app currently
in our browser, and I've opened this project
file as well. So what are we going to do now?
So we're going to go to Chrome Developer Tools
by clicking on inspect and go to lighthouse.
So what lighthouse allows us to do, it's
gonna scan our app, and it's gonna tell us
what are the features that are missing to make it
a progressive web app. So it's gonna in your case,
it's going to show you all of these icons as
ticked. So you need to antique all of these
icons except the progressive web app and click on
Generate Report. So it's gonna scan your website
and tell you what are the things that are missing
to create it progressive web app. So let's check.
Alright, here we go. So these are the things
these are the red errors are the things that
we need to complete. So first of all, let's start
from the bottom. So first of all, it's asking us
that manifest doesn't have a maskable icon. So we
need to create a maskable icon. But first of all,
what I'm going to do is, you can see that, first
of all, let's go to the application tab, you can
see that this icon has these react icons. So we
don't want this react icons, we're gonna change
this icons to our own icon of the app. So let's
go to Google and search dictionary, I can PNG,
here you go. Let's go to images. And we're going
to have that icon with in which we have full usage
rights. Let's go click over here. And let's choose
this icon. And I'm going to click on this icons,
it's gonna take us to the website, and from
here, we can freely download this icon, oh,
we need to register. Let me quickly do that.
Okay, so we have download that icon over here,
it's going to be free, it's not going to cost any
money. So let's convert this icon into a favicon.
So we're gonna go to the browser, and type
PNG to favicon. Let's go to this website.
And we need to drag and drop our file
over here. So let's take this file,
and drop it over here. And
let's click on download.
So it has provided us with this zip file. Let's
keep our zip file over here and extract it.
Alright, here we are. So what are the files that
we need? We're going to need this one. Okay, we're
gonna need all of these. And this one. Yeah. Let's
cut this icons over here. And we're going to go to
over here into public folder, and we're going
to paste it over here and replace the file. And
here we have it, we have these fabric on file. So
we're here we're gonna remove both of these files.
Yeah, we don't need them, we're gonna remove them.
Alright, so let's go back to our code. And into
our public folder in index dot HTML, we're going
to need to add a few lines. So right over here,
you can see there's an apple touch icon
over here. So we just gonna change the H ref
to something else. Let's see what was the name
of our file. Here's the name of our file, Apple
touch icon dot png. So Apple, touch icon dot png,
here we go. It has auto suggested as this name.
And the other thing that we need to
add is our favicon. icon. So link,
short. Got it? All right, now
we need to give it an href.
So it's gonna be fairly corny. If I'm not
wrong. Let me check. Yeah, favicon dot Ico.
Yes, we need that. There we go. What's wrong?
Okay, we haven't closed the tag. Now we're done.
Let's go to our website and check. Here
you go. You can see the icon has changed.
Let me just reload this page, and go
to inspect and go to application. Now
we can see over here you can see our
fabric code has changed successfully.
Now what do we need to do for this step
two is we need to generate a manifest file.
So what is a manifest dot JSON file, if you go
to your react app, you can see this something
on manifest dot Jason. It has it favicon dot
Ico. It has the logos, different different logos
or logo files that we deleted. We're not going
to use this, we didn't delete that right here.
And I'm going to delete this as well. We don't
need this. I'm going to delete those as well.
Basically everything we're going to delete it
over. First of all, let me generate your manifest
files data. So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go to this website
Manny, fast generator. Let's see. Here we go.
Hey, you have it. Let's give our app a name.
Word hunt. I'm going to give it short name of word
hunt. Team color. Let's say I'm going to choose
black. All right. display mode is going to be
standalone because we want this to be acting as
a native app. So we're gonna do is stand alone.
Orientation. It depends on your app. If your app
Support support rate as well as landscape, you
can select any. In my case, I'm going to select
any application scope, no nothing to change over
here. So here we go. We have this manifest data
generated. So I'm going to copy it up. And I'm
going to go to our VS code and paste it over here.
Comma is needed over there. Yeah. All right, now
we need to generate our icons. So how are we going
to do that? So earlier, we have downloaded
that file. Where is it? Yeah, word hunt,
we're going to use that to generate our different
different sizes. So there are four sizes that
you need to generate. First one is 190 2x
192, second, 256 3354, and fourth is 512.
Let's go to our browser. And let's enter image
size. Yeah, let's go to Image resizer.com.
Alright, here we are, we're gonna supply
it our image right here. So first of all,
what do we need, we're gonna need to generate
192 x 192. Here we go. Resize image now.
Alright, here we are, there's download this image.
Here we go. So we're gonna
go to our project folder.
And we're gonna paste it over here. So let's
just drag and drop over here. So here it is.
Now second one. Also, I'm going to
name it. Let's name it logo. 192.
We're going to follow this convention. Alright,
let's generate another one. Let's take that.
I'm just going to generate for everything then
I'm going to paste it all together over there.
Second one is 256 into 256. There's
download that. The third one.
Yeah, that third one was 384 into 384. Here we go.
Final file will be 512 and 251251
2x. Five one to resize that image.
Alright, here we go. See had
mistakenly downloaded it twice?
gonna delete it? Oh, no, nevermind. Alright,
so we're gonna copy all of these files
to this folder, public folder. And then I'm
going to name them the same way that I named
this logo one and two. So this one is logo 256.
This one is logo. 384. And this one was logo.
512. Here we are. Alright, so we have all of
the icons generated successfully. Alright,
let's go to our VS code. And let's create our
icons. So what we're supposed to do now is this.
We're gonna enter that. So what
have I done over here? Let's see.
Yeah, so we're going to provide the
SRC of wherever the location of icon
is. I'm gonna remove this. And type logo
192. Same for this one as well. Logo 256.
Logo 384. Lastly, logo 512. Let's see
what application. Let's save it. Yeah,
and let's go to the Chrome. Let's refresh this
page. compiled successfully. Let's go to inspect
and application. There we have it. We have
all of the icons over here. Great. And also
we need to add a ServiceWorker. I'm going to
explain what ServiceWorker is later. Let's
go to our lighthouse over here. Let's generate
the report. And now let's start working on that.
Alright, first one is that manifest doesn't
have a mascot bell icon. So what is the mascot
bell icon. So masco bell icon is something
that when you install the app in your phone,
the icon And that is displayed over there
in your menu. That is what mostly well I
can is. So how do we generate a maskable icon.
So there's a website called mass cable dot app.
I'm going to close both of these, I'm going
to go to Mass cable, dot app slash editor.
Here we are. So we need to provide it. First of
all, we need to provide our icon or the image
that we need to use. So this one, I'm going to
drag and drop over here. So here we are. Now
we need to make it according to our, you know,
according to our liking, so I'm gonna do is,
let's say, rounded rectangle. Yeah, that
looks good. I'm gonna provide it a little
bit of padding. I'm going to shift it a little bit
over here. That looks good. I think that's good.
I think that looks fine. Yeah, so I'm just
gonna export it. It has downloaded that. Let's
go to our public folder. And I'm going to
drag and drop that over here. Let's drag and
drop over here. I'm going to give it
the name of maskable. maskable. Yeah,
great. So now in our manifest file, we need
to provide the location of this maskable.
Let's go to the manifest or JSON. And at the top
over here, I'm going to open another curly brace.
Just like the others, we need to provide
it as RC First of all, whoops, as C.
So what is going to be the SRC maskable.
The name that we gave, must not be in. jpg.
So what's the size, size is going
to be 1-967-219-6196. In 2196.
It is we need to add the type type
is going to be image slash PNG.
And the purpose purpose is going
to be any maskable. Here it is.
Let's save that. And let's check our website.
Let's go here, over here and refresh it. I'm going
to close it and open into a new tab. Go to inspect
To the Lighthouse and Generate Report. Once again.
All right, here you go. Manifest has a mascot
bell icon. Let's see what else is left. Better.
Alright, next thing, what do we need to do is
does not redirect HTTP traffic to HTTPS. So
it's gonna be fixed when we deploy it to netlify.
Since netlify, directs all the traffic to HTTPS,
so it's not going to be the problem. So let's
leave this one for now. And the third one is that
does not register a ServiceWorker, that controls
page and start URL. So all of these three are
linked together. So we need to provide that let's
go over here. Where is it? So as you can see,
we don't have any ServiceWorker file currently. So
how do we need to generate the ServiceWorker file?
So let's go to a new window. What I'm
going to do is, I'm going to open a folder.
Let's open a folder right over here. I'm gonna
name this folder, service. work or something,
anything doesn't really matter. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to initialize a new react app.
But it's not going to be the conventional way.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to enter NP x
create react app. And what do we need to do? Yeah,
we need to write any any name, let's say my app.
And I'm gonna write a template
for CR a dash template, dash pw A. So when you
type this, it's going to generate a react app,
especially configured for a pw a application.
So let's enter that. And let's see what happens.
Alright, here we go. It has successfully
initialized a new react app.
So what do we need from this react app? We
need these two files serviceworker.js and
service worker registration dot j s we're
so we're gonna select these and copy these
and copy these into our Project over here into
the src folder, I'm going to go and paste it.
So we have both of these ServiceWorker files.
Let's go back to that project. And let's go
inside of index dot j s, let's see how these files
are being used. So it's being used over here.
And we need to add this line as well. So I'm
going to add this line first, let's import that,
copy and paste into our index.js file. Here we go.
Let's go back. And let's copy this part as well.
Copy and paste it over here. And let's save
that. And let's see the app has compiled
successfully. Let's go back to our local host.
And I'm going to open this in new tab again.
Let's go to inspect and check
lighthouse. Let's read the report.
All right, let's see what happened.
Okay, it's still giving the same error.
Why? Because Because of this, when you go to
index, sorry, ServiceWorker, there's something
called inside of register, you can see it only
works on a production app. So our app is currently
in development. So let's build this app. And let's
see if it works or not. So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to type NPM, run, build. So it's going
to build our app, a production ready app. Alright,
first of all, whoa, whoa, whoa, we forgot to do
this. Instead of unregister. We need to change
it to register. Yes, so that it can register
our ServiceWorker. So now let's run the build.
Alright, app has been built successfully. So what
does it say it say you can run this command to run
the production build. But first of all, if you
don't have this, sir, what do you need to do?
You can run NPM I sir, dash g when you run this
command, sorry, not an om, it's NPM. So when you
run this command, what it's gonna do, it's gonna
install this command server on your machine.
So let's just run this command now. Sir, dash s
build. I'm going to copy it and run it over here.
So it says it is serving on our localhost
in our localhost 5000. So let's go to
localhost 5000. Now. localhost, I'm going to
change this to 5000. And our app is running,
let's go to inspect and to the lighthouse.
And let's generate the report again.
All right, here you go. These checks ended the
experto. Now you can see it has lightened up
this progressive web app icon. So all we need to
do now is does not redirect HTTP traffic to HTTPS.
So when you deploy this app to netlify, so what
it's going to do, it's going to have successfully
direct all the traffic from HTTP to HTTPS, then
it's going to be created as a progressive web app.
So if you don't know how to deploy this app
on netlify, you can check our previous video
where I have where we have created this dictionary
app. So let's check our deployed website. Now.
Let's go to word hunt dot netlify dot app.
This is our deployed website. Now final check
of First of all, you can see there's
one Install button over here.
If I click on this install button, it's going to
ask me to install this app, just like I showed you
earlier in phone. This is how you can install
it on your desktop. Let's click on Install.
And here you go in this app has been installed
successfully. Here you go. Our app is right here,
word hunt when we click on it, it has installed as
a native app in our PC. And check the final time
there's a new report and it's going to show us
that our app is now successfully a pw a. Hey,
you go. There you have it. Our progressive app is
working fine progressive web app is working fine.